Traductor: Carmen de Miguel-Murado
Revisor: Penny Martínez
La alarma de nuestro móvil
nos despierta cada mañana.
Con nuestra huella digital lo encendemos
y empezamos a ver
los mensajes de la noche anterior.
Empezamos a encender apps:
la del tiempo, para saber
qué ropa ponernos,
mientras nos vamos preparando
hay alarmas, citas,
la agenda digital
nos está haciendo nuestra jornada.
Cogemos el coche y con el GPS
nos saltamos los atascos
y llegamos a nuestra oficina,
donde nuestro día se desenvuelve
entre ordenadores, cables,
máquinas y tecnología
que nos hacen la vida más fácil.
Nuestra vida ya es digital.
Uno de los sectores que ha vivido una
de las mayores disrupciones tecnológicas
es el sector de la banca.
Solo en la primera mitad del 2018
las Fintech invirtieron
más de EUR 41 billones
en innovación tecnológica,
todo para digitalizar la relación
entre los bancos y sus clientes.
Bizums, Paypal, transferencias
desde el móvil.
Ya todo lo hacemos desde casa.
¿Hace cuánto que no vais
a una sucursal bancaria?
Dentro de poco aún más.
A través de nuestro rostro
o nuestra voz, con la biometría,
vamos incluso a poder pagar, tal cual,
sin un teléfono móvil.
Dentro de nada vamos a tener
una identidad digital
que nos va a permitir mandar dinero
a cualquier persona del mundo,
y sin comisiones.
Y todo esto, ¿para qué?
Pues para hacernos la vida
más fácil a nosotros,
las personas más afortunadas.
En 2009 conocí a Amrita.
Amrita vivía en un slam,
debajo de un puente en Nueva Delhi,
con sus padres, que eran alcohólicos.
Por el día, Amrita mendigaba,
intentando conseguir unas pocas rupias
para comprar comida
y alcohol para sus padres.
Con bastante esfuerzo conseguimos
que sus padres le dejasen participar
en un programa para diez niñas
cuyo objetivo era rehabilitarlas,
sacarlas de la calle.
Sin embargo, cuando habían pasado
seis meses del programa,
nos llama su padre y nos dice:
o nos dais 12 000 rupias
(aproximadamente EUR 200)
o nos devolvéis a Amrita,
porque esa es la cantidad
que nos acaba de ofrecer por ella
una mafia de explotación sexual.
(Aplausos)
Ese momento fue el primer
gran dilema al que me enfrenté
cuando llegué a India como cooperante,
dispuesta a cambiar el mundo.
En ese momento podía cambiar
la vida de Amrita por EUR 200 míseros.
Pero la teoría era clara:
no hay que pagarlos,
entras en corrupciones,
mañana te van a pedir 200 más.
El dinero de la ONG
se nos acabaría en días,
pero claro, no pagarlos suponía
que esta niña acabaría prostituida
y que, además, los seis meses
que llevábamos trabajando con ella
no hubiesen servido de nada,
dinero tirado a la basura.
¿Qué dirían los donantes?
Khushbu era otra de las niñas
de la casa de acogida.
Tenía una mirada, una sonrisa,
tremendamente impactantes,
sin embargo, su cuerpo estaba quemado.
Los niños de la calle
son tremendamente vulnerables,
tienen muchísimo miedo a los adultos
y cuesta mucho conocer su identidad,
conocer su pasado.
Tardamos meses en hacer
la rehabilitación psicosocial,
pero descubrimos por qué se había quemado.
Se había prendido fuego a ella misma
porque quería dar asco a los hombres,
incluido su padre,
que abusaban de ella sexualmente
cada noche en las estaciones de tren.
Diez niñas pasaron por el programa.
Diez historias reales,
cada cual más impactante.
Solo diez de los más
de 10 millones de niños y niñas
que viven en las calles de India.
Solo 10 de los entre 100 y 150 millones
de niños que hay hoy en nuestro mundo,
en la calle,
y que deambulan entre ciudades,
entre estaciones,
huyendo de mafias,
huyendo muchas veces
de sus propios padres,
millones de invisibles
que intentan subsistir
en la fortuna de esa invisibilidad
para no caer en los infiernos de la
esclavitud, de la mafia, de los abusos.
Y no solo son invisibles
porque no les veamos,
son invisibles porque
para la sociedad, no existen.
No hablamos solo de niños
en situación de calle.
A esto hay que sumarle más de
70 millones de personas refugiadas,
más de 20 millones de víctimas de trata
y los millones de personas
que nacieron en zonas remotas,
quizás en el lugar equivocado,
donde precisamente por eso
no fueron registradas al nacer.
Hablamos de más del 20 %
de la población mundial
que no tienen un documento de identidad
que les acredite como
ciudadanos con derechos.
¿Os habéis planteado alguna vez
que ese documento de identidad,
ese papel plastificado que tiene
vuestros datos de identidad,
que tenéis todos vosotros
en vuestras carteras,
es lo que os hace visibles
ante la sociedad?
Imaginaos por unos segundos
vuestra vida sin ese trozo de papel.
Pues Amrita, Khushbu y las otras 8 niñas
que pasaron por nuestro programa
fueron las que visibilizaron para mí
esa invisibilidad,
y fueron la motivación
por la que dejé mi trabajo
en banca de inversión en Irlanda
para quedarme en la India
y trabajar en innovación social.
En un mundo en el que la tecnología
está transformando todo,
solucionando todos nuestros problemas,
incluso aquellos que, si lo piensas,
no son problemas.
Yo me preguntaba:
¿Cómo puede ser que la tecnología no haya
ayudado a acabar con este sinsentido?
¿Cómo puede ser que todos los sectores
han sido transformados
completamente por la tecnología,
digitalizándose para llegar a sus clientes
de manera más rápida,
más barata, más efectiva,
sabiendo quiénes son,
sabiendo sus necesidades?
¿Cómo puede ser que el sector social
que tiene al cliente mas vulnerable,
con las necesidades más absolutas
y que sí tienen que ser
solucionadas de manera urgente,
siga trabajando de una forma tan precaria?
Fue ahí cuando descubrí lo que para mí
es el primer gran reto del sector social,
y es precisamente hacer
visibles a estos invisibles,
el tema del registro.
Si no podemos cuantificar los problemas,
si no sabemos quiénes los padecen,
¿cómo vamos a solucionarlos realmente?
¿cómo vamos las ONGs a atenderles bien?
Descubrí que las ONGs trabajamos
prácticamente con papel y lápiz,
que después ponemos
los datos en unos Excel,
en el mejor de los casos en bases
de datos más o menos sofisticadas,
pero la rotación de personal,
de cooperantes,
hace que muchas veces esas bases de datos
se pierdan, cambien con el tiempo.
Y además, si las personas
con las que trabajamos
no tienen un documento de identidad,
¿cómo sabemos realmente
que son quienes dicen ser?
Si hoy viene una persona
a recibir un servicio,
y mañana vuelve y dice
llamarse de otra manera,
probablemente volvamos a darle el servicio
y además, les registraremos una vez más.
Me empecé a preguntar
qué usábamos en banca
para gestionar las identidades.
La biometría.
Y fue así como decidimos desarrollar
un sistema de reconocimiento biométrico
que hoy permite a ONGs y a gobiernos
identificar con altísima fiabilidad
a estos colectivos invisibles,
y además gestionar sus datos
en bases de datos seguras, eficientes,
y digo seguras porque además
es muy importante
la seguridad de estos datos.
Hablamos de datos muy sensibles,
de identidades.
Los encriptamos y los subimos a la nube
precisamente para eso.
Con la biometría podemos
registrar a millones de niños
como Khushbu y Amrita,
que hoy están en Delhi,
pero mañana tienen miedo,
cogen un tren y estarán en Mombay,
que hoy dicen llamarse Amrita
pero a lo mejor mañana,
al trabajador social de Mombay,
le dicen que son Priyanka, por miedo.
Es lógico.
Con esta tecnología
podemos protegerles mejor,
podemos tener datos
mucho más fiables y eficientes
para tomar mejores decisiones.
Y esto es lo que estamos haciendo
precisamente ya en la India,
en una red de más de 80 ONGs
que trabajan conectadas,
y que desde 2013 han identificado ya
a más de 300 000 niños.
Estamos ahora escalando la solución
a países como Senegal y Sierra Leona
gracias al trabajo y colaboración
con otras entidades.
Con biometría descubrí la solución
al tema del registro en el sector.
Pero claro, mi mente,
obsesionada por la eficiencia,
probablemente por mi pasado en el banco,
me llevó a descubrir un segundo reto
que tiene el sector social,
y es cómo garantizamos
que el dinero llega,
cómo lo optimizamos al máximo,
cómo podemos hacer
esa trazabilidad tan perfecta
que hacemos en el banco con el dinero,
cómo podemos exprimir
cada euro, optimizarlo,
igual que hacía en banca de inversión.
Encontré la solución en 2017,
en otra tecnología, en blockchain.
Si Internet vino para
digitalizar la comunicación
y transformó por completo
cómo nos comunicamos,
blockchain ha venido
para digitalizar activos
y para intercambiarlos digitalmente
y transformar completamente
cómo lo hacemos,
por ejemplo, el dinero.
Con blockchain podemos digitalizarlo
y trazar en todo momento dónde está,
pero no solo el dinero,
por ejemplo, un contrato.
Con blockchain podemos garantizar
que unos fondos salen
de una cuenta bancaria
solo y únicamente
cuando se cumplen ciertos hitos.
Como os podéis imaginar, los bancos están
invirtiendo millones en esta tecnología.
Sin embargo, no se me ocurre un sector
para el que la trazabilidad del dinero
sea más importante, que el sector social,
que está puramente basado en la confianza.
¿Os imagináis recibir un SMS
cuando EUR 10 que donasteis hace seis
meses a una ONG se acaban de ejecutar,
y saber exactamente en qué?
Y más aún:
¿Os imagináis saber el impacto
social que han tenido esos EUR 10
porque además, una persona o varias
se han beneficiado de esos servicios
y pueden validarlo con la tecnología?
¿No es maravilloso?
Pues bien, hoy la tecnología lo permite.
Y por eso estamos desarrollando
una plataforma digital en blockchain,
un ecosistema del bien común,
para que las organizaciones puedan
gestionar sus proyectos
de manera transparente.
Y los individuos y las organizaciones
que los financian,
que invierten en esos proyectos,
puedan tener la garantía de todo esto.
Como habéis visto,
la biometría puede solucionar
el primer gran reto del registro,
y blockchain puede ayudarnos
a garantizar que la solidaridad llega
y que se gestiona de manera más eficiente.
Llegamos al tercer y último
gran reto con el que me encontré:
¿Quién financia todo esto?
¿Estamos dispuestos?
Invertir en innovación tecnológica
en el entorno social es caro,
como en cualquier sector.
Hay que asumir riesgos.
¿Estamos dispuestos los donantes
a asumir esos riesgos?
¿Y los grandes fondos filantrópicos?
¿Y las empresas a través de su RSC?
Pues la respuesta, con mi experiencia,
es que, tristemente, todavía no.
Y es muy frustrante.
Quien no arriesga, no gana.
Y estamos hablando
de ganar la batalla al hambre,
a la desnutrición, a la trata,
al trabajo infantil.
Llevamos años intentando solucionar
todos esos problemas,
y no los hemos solucionado.
¿No es de cajón que hay que innovar?
Todos los sectores se han transformado
completamente con la tecnología.
Sectores como la ciencia.
En los bancos han conseguido
grandes avances gracias a la tecnología.
Hoy podemos viajar a la Luna.
Podemos hacer una
transferencia desde el móvil.
Estoy convencidísima
de que podemos acabar
con el trabajo infantil.
Sin embargo, si no dejamos
a las ONGs, a las personas,
a las organizaciones que estamos
al lado de esos problemas,
que los conocemos perfectamente
y que tenemos las ideas para solucionarlos
invertir en tecnología,
invertir en innovación social,
desde luego, no lo vamos
a poder conseguir.
Hay quien dice que la solución
está en el emprendimiento social.
Y efectivamente, yo estoy de acuerdo
en que hacen falta modelos de negocio,
modelos de sostenibilidad
para estos proyectos.
Pero hay problemas
para los cuales la solución
no tiene un modelo de negocio,
por lo menos, no a corto plazo, sencillo.
Y ahí es donde está la filantropía.
Ahí es donde debemos estar.
Ahí está la solidaridad.
Porque una empresa, probablemente,
nunca hubiese estado
en aquel slam en Nueva Delhi,
nunca hubiese estado al lado
ni hubiese identificado
esos problemas de Khushbu y Amrita,
porque nunca hubiese estado trabajando
en un programa de rehabilitación
de solo diez niñas,
un programa sin ningún modelo de negocio.
Ahí solo está la solidaridad.
Una empresa, probablemente,
nunca hubiese pagado
los EUR 200 que nosotros
sí pagamos por Amrita.
Para una empresa era un riego muy grande,
para la filantropía no lo es.
Porque salvar a una niña
de ser prostituida
siempre tiene sentido.
Y no se puede hablar
ni de inversión ni de riesgo,
ni de ninguna de esas palabras.
Trabajo para llevar
la tecnología más avanzada
a donde realmente más se necesita.
Y lo hago con modelos de sostenibilidad.
Sin embargo, mientras eso sucede,
mientras conseguimos que no haya más niñas
como Amrita y Khushbo en la calle,
lo que sí tengo claro es que
una vida nunca tiene precio.
Y cuando hablamos de solucionar problemas,
de salvar vidas como la de Khushbu
en momentos tan difíciles,
en situaciones tan complejas,
no hay más modelo de negocio
que la solidaridad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)